do you
when you're working with your wife and
we'll move on here but when you're
working with her is there any times
where she's like joe joe i get it i get
it i get it or you have those moments
and do you talk about these moments
before they happen like look we're
working close together i'm directing you
i'm going to say things you're going to
get mad at me i want more i want more i
want more and and i'm your husband and
this is gonna be odd yeah um we did talk
about it and um you know we got through
it
there was only one episode it was
totally my fault and i did
i didn't lose my cool but the the the
you know i was it was in the first two
one or it was like maybe it's day three
um and
we were at the end of the day
and it was completely unprofessional on
my part but i'm gonna come clean because
this is what this podcast is about we're
getting inside of me come clean please
i'm gonna come clean and you know was uh
by the way i'll tell you if it was your
fault no it definitely was my fault
and and you know as you know she asked
as any actor would do she's like
what you know what am i
what's what's my action here what am i
supposed to be doing exactly
and i thought it was kind of obvious
what she was supposed to be doing and i
was also it was a long day i was a
little stressed
um and i said your action is
we have 15 minutes to get this shot and
then it's the end of the day
and i was very mortified and ashamed and
she's like okay and and then she did the
action and
it wasn't
what i it wasn't right because i didn't
tell her what to do
and we had to kind of reset this kind of
big thing it was totally my fault and
she was so annoyed had every right to be
uh with me but i i effed up for sure in
that moment but i will say that that
really was the only
moment like that throughout the whole
uh show where i and because i've learned
the lesson i'm like just learn your
lesson early i learned it early and you
know and it was during the big climactic
scene at the end and there was certain
you know um pacing of action that i
needed and i just wasn't clear
and um anyway so that was the lesson
learned and other than that we were we
were spot-on fantastic i love working
with her and it was great
because
you know i wrote the role with her in
mind and i knew that she had all the
levels to play it and then then watching
her do it i'm like man there's still
more there that i didn't see she was
terrific